German authorities have foiled an
alleged plot that aimed to topple the
government in Berlin by force dozens of
arrests were made in overnight raids
that spanned the nation they targeted
suspected supporters of a far-right
movement that rejects the legitimacy of
the current German State the country's
top federal prosecutor said the alleged
coup plotters intended to form a new
German Army and install a minor
Aristocrat as the country's leader and
let's get more now from DW political
correspondent Benjamin Alvarez Gruber
who's been following this very closely
for us today Benjamin an alleged plot to
overthrow the German government how big
was the real threat here
it was definitely a big threat and
there's also what Authority said today
this group started meeting back in
November of last year they had regular
meetings in as we just heard in the
report there was a political arm and
there was also one in charge of weapons
in charge of also getting a people from
security forces from the police to go
together with this plan to overthrow the
government and it goes that way that
they even went into bundeswear Barracks
to see were their own soldiers it would
be based so it's pretty concrete the
plans that they had already and as we
also saw in the report that they had
individuals who would take then this
positions as had of this new government
or as a Justice minister so that's also
something that authorities repeated
today by saying that the threat was real
and if we look back how this
investigation started it was indeed the
connection between this group of the
people that were arrested in another
group that wanted to kidnap Germany's
Health Minister a car lautaba so that's
where this is litigation started and
where that ended also with all the raids
in several German cities today detaining
these 25 people they will now face
Justice
politicians and
authorities reacted to the news
so there have been two reactions on one
side praising the police officers that
were involved in the raids and also the
domestic intelligence services that also
conducted all the investigation over the
past months this is a pretty long
process and on other side they're also
showing how deep this goes into the
problems that we have seen in the many
are saying that German authorities have
a blind eye on right-wing extremism one
of those who reacted as German president
Frankfurter Steinway who said this
incident represents a new level in the
extremist threats something similar that
government spokes a person Stefan
hibischlight said that is extremely a
dangerous pointing out the plans that
you also mentioned of attacking and of
disarmed assault on the bundest side of
the lower House of Germany's Parliament
at let's talk about these accusations of
turning a blind eye toward far-right
extremism and the possibility and the
growing threat of political violence
what more can you tell us about that
there have been some attacks in the past
years that have been a murder of a
conservative politician of another fight
right far right extremists that also did
an attack on a synagogue and what
domestic intelligence Services have been
accused on is having a blind eye when it
comes to right-wing extremism but
therefore focusing on islamists and also
on left-wing extremism and that's
something that the former German
interior Minister Jose Hoffa said saying
that there has been an increase of cases
and they should take this more seriously
and what many are asking the government
to do and asking the intelligence
service is not looking at just loan
people who want to commit this attacks
but also when there's a structural
problem when we look at police officers
and when we look also at the armed
forces and that's a big problem of this
reisberger movement that many of those
who are in this group are in this
right-wing extremist group they do not
accept Germany the German order and the
Constitution also know how to deal with
weapons and have also access it to
classified information that's why many
see that this reisberger movement is
especially so dangerous and are taking
this threats and also this rates very
very carefully DW political
correspondent Benjamin Alvarez grupa
thank you we can now speak to till
stethan he's a member of the German
Parliament for the green party which is
one of the Coalition Partners in the
government welcome to DW Mr Stefan
thousands of officers more than 100
raids across the country what's this
telling us about the the threat level of
what happened today
of course it's a serious wrap if you see
that you have so many suspects arrested
today and the threat is very special
because we have soldiers we have
policemen and we have even a judge among
those arrested people who was planning
to to do the school today these days and
then
um you can see it's really a problem
that that are not only extremists in
some some groups anywhere because but
there are inside the structures of the
state and so we must take it very
serious and we must do everything to
throw out people of police off the army
of the judge system who are extremists
like those arrested today
that the people involved in this
movement known as reisberger tended to
be let's say belittled or ridiculed here
in Germany for their World Views rather
than being taken seriously how big a
mistake would you say that was in
hindsight
um of course they seem to be kind of
ridiculous because they had their own
passports and things like that but in
fact they are undermined
um the the German State because many
people wasn't willing to respect the
German State authorities
um because of those of those groups and
inside those groups some of them
became more and more extremistic and
were taking plans to overflow the state
as we see today and of course if people
exist and those ideas that there is no
such thing as a federal republic of
Germany then they are ready to to use
forces one day so I think we should take
them very very seriously and we should
be very careful
especially not having people of the
reisberger seen in the police in the
Army and other state institutions so
you've said very clearly that we need to
take this very seriously of course I
ideas like that conversations like this
grow online so what is going to be done
I mean will monitoring people with with
extremist views
um uh you know their safe spaces on on
social media what will be done to to
track them more more seriously
the fact that we have this uh this big
activities that police today shows that
the police and the Secret Service is
able to track them very carefully and
attract them for many many months so
where they were able
um to arrest such a big group of people
planning to do such a coup so I'm quite
confident of the work of the police and
the Secret Service and we can say that
we have a very clear view on a big part
of the scene but of course it's not
everything of it and there are many more
people and we have to look very
carefully in social media and other
groups but of course there is no
relevant telegram group without any
um spotters of the Secret Service or the
police
Mr chef and I do just want to ask you
about the fact that a member of
Germany's far-right afd party is also
among those arrested afd lawmakers sit
in Germany's Parliament with you every
day to what extent are they are a threat
to democracy
in Parliament they are working on making
the work of parliament ridiculous and so
they work on weakening the respect of a
parliament every day that that's what we
see every day in every committee meeting
and every day but at the same time we
see we have strugglings to the extremist
right-wing movement they have people
working for the RFD in German bundeslaq
who have who has who are extremists um
that we very let me know very exactly
and also this judge invested today was
known as an externus but the present
rules doesn't work on on pulling them
out of public service and we have the
same thing with the judge returning to
his job's job last year after the last
election in Saxony
and there was a decision that he could
be taken out of public service but it's
very difficult to do this and we have to
strengthen the rules in order to keep
actions out of Public Service
till Stefan the German lawmaker with the
green party thank you so much for your
time
thank you
and we're going to go back to our top
story today the alleged plot that aimed
to topple the German government in
Berlin by force and for more on that I'm
very pleased to welcome to BS Ginsburg a
writer and journalist whose books are
based on
um long term undercover investigations
for months he lived under a false
identity among German right-wing Fringe
groups like The iceburger Tobias thanks
so much for joining us today on DW can
you help us understand how people like
the rice Burger as they're known how
they think what what is their goal
well um the core of the so-called
reisberger movement is some something
extremely dangerous because it's
extremely common
our problem is in Germany it's not with
this specific group it's far worse it's
with with right-wing conspiracy theories
those are theories which we had in
Germany since 1945 it's like a prologing
of Nazi ideology the idea that our
German state is not uh real and
authentic and legal state but just are
plot by the vengeful jewelry or by the
Allies or by some other occult forces
the great plot the great conspiracy and
this is an idea we have in Germany since
1945.
so I just want to clarify there so that
this is going back to the second world
war and they are saying that the German
state is is somehow false has been set
up by by other countries by the allies
sure sure Hitler promised us a thousand
years we only got 12. so all Nazis were
not satisfied they wanted more so in
beginning in 1945 we had this conspiracy
theory that whatever state will be built
on top of the Third Reich that state
will not be legitimate and now we have
something to do against that if you ask
in Germany any Neo-Nazi they will say of
course the federal republic is not our
real Germany and now the evil thing the
a horrible thing is that this notion
came into different Millions different
scenes into the bourgeoisie into the
center of society via conspiracy
theories so the plot or the attempted
plot we saw just now today just shows
exactly that those people who are not
all like classically from the far right
those were people from from the center
of society the people from Parliament
people from from uh Bourgeois jobs and
and all walks of life so from what
you're saying this is really quite
widespread this way of thinking can you
explain to us then how they're
organizing I mean they must be aware
that they're under they're under police
surveillance so how are they organizing
themselves
it's very difficult to generalize in our
movements with so many people because we
have all different kinds of groups and
movements I myself join people who were
like extremely esoteric new agey Cults
then you had like far right sex some
people were more or less normal
neo-nazis as you would imagine them
so um they all work a little bit
different and the official numbers we
have like I don't know like a hundred
thousand people who belong more or less
to this movement this is a very loose
estimate okay
just just to look beautiful
if I could just ask you to sort of go in
more specifically at the people involved
among the people arrested today are an
active member of the German armed forces
and several reservists
so how much help are these far-right
networks getting from the very inside of
Germany's security apparatus
foreign
again I cannot tell you any concrete
numbers plus if you go inside this is of
course an extremely concrete goal the
hope to get soldiers to get people from
the police to get people uh from within
the state is of course a very attractive
girl for most of these people
on the other hand many people say they
would be extremely well connected
because it sounds sounds very good so we
have to differentiate differentiate how
dangerous how imminent is a huge attack
I don't think this is the problem I
think the far greater problem is how
many people are reached by this way of
thought and that The Logical conclusion
is not only to topple the state top of
the government or whatever but to act in
self-defense to work against the state
to work against the police the higher
apps who are out to getcha
the German government said that the
police raids today were proof that
authorities are Vigilant that they're on
top of things what do you think about
that statement
well I mean um this problem is nothing
new
and if I think back just in the last few
years we had this horrible mass murder
this terrorist attack by a conspiracy
theorists who believed all the same
things the people who were gotten today
thought as well we had a murder from
some uh anti-vaxxer at a gas station we
have a violent Deeds again and again
so it's not this one event it's a string
of events it's a way of thinking which
spreads at a rapid pace
to be a skinsberg author and journalist
uh we'll have to leave it there but
thank you so much for those really
fascinating insights
and let's bring in Lawrence blumenthalo
he's a spokesperson for the Amadeo
Antonio Foundation here in Germany which
works to promote human rights and oppose
extremism and anti-Semitism Mr
blumenthaler good to see you what does
the scale of today's raids tell you
about the threat emanating from
right-wing extremist groups here in
Germany
I mean it's basically Something That
We're observing over the last and also
warning about the last four years we are
facing a serious crisis of democracy the
covet pandemic spread of conspiracy
beliefs and also the underestimation of
right-wing extremism have contributed to
extreme forms of radicalization
especially in the digital space
as today has shown it's not just French
conspiracy Believers but also judges
former bundestag members and active form
assault or former soldiers also from the
special forces that were part of this
network that was persecuted today and
this alone shows how seriously we need
to take this threat during the long been
accused of of turning a blind eye on
especially right-wing extremism but
authorities say that today's raids prove
the state is Vigilant and on top of
things do you share this assessment
I think on the one hand today for the
first time we've seen a glimpse of what
politicians like to call a defense of
democracy and I'm very happy that uh
today they acted upon that promise
but on the other hand I think
the mistakes that have been made in the
past won't just be solved by good police
work we need furthermore we need a
holistic approach that strengthens also
prevention and the radicalization
measures
and democracy education
um because otherwise I don't think that
this will go away anytime soon how
concerning are the groups ties to
Germany's security apparatus
I think it is very concerning that
former and armed soldiers are always
part of these networks when they um
finally gets toppled by the police and
um I think that is something that's the
politicians and police forces need to
deal with themselves and not just
externalize it by some of the raids but
we also need better education and
um
some sort of awareness Within These
institutions as well democracy work
doesn't stop within the police so
so the threat has been made visible but
by no means eliminated you talk about
education but there are sectors of
society you know the the ringleader of
this group he he was I believe in his
late 60s how do you reach people who are
so advanced in age and probably also
pretty settled in their world views with
initiatives of Education as you suggest
yeah I think when we talk about
education I don't just mean like uh
classical school education but
furthermore
um we rather need to tackle all parts
and aspects of society for instance also
um people that work that do
administrative work especially in
regards with the reisberger ideology
um oftentimes they are confronted with
this forms of ideology in the first
place when people want to burn the
passport or hand them their ID because
they don't believe in the existence of
the German state so I think that is
something where different parts of the
German State and administrative body
should cooperate it just much better to
to tackle these issues and
radicalization tendencies much earlier
before they turn 60 and have a closed
world view
um you say that we're in a crisis of
democracy in Germany that how resilient
is the Democracy here in the country in
this in this crisis as you call it
I think it is more resilient than
um than we like to believe in in a lot
of ways
um because first there was 2015 2016
um the summer of migration then we had
a massive racist
um mobilization that then transferred
into the covet pandemic and the
anti-vaxxers and the spread of
conspiracy beliefs and now we Face
Russian best information and the energy
crisis which also draws a lot of people
into conspiracy beliefs and writing
extremism but I think especially the the
good work of civil society and
on some parts also the German state has
contributed to a rather resilient German
democracy including the work of your
organization the amadio Antonio
Foundation Lawrence blumen tarlo thank
you so much